a few hours on the board together in one
at a time now let's make it was number
one so you've got an equation and you'll
see by the way I I go out your questions
a lot and I want you to be able to look
at these things and develop what our
math teachers call fluency smooth is
usually a word you associate with
language like I am fluent in English
English Cantonese whatever it is
whatever languages you speak I've only
spoken english but fluency is important
because when you speak a language in
which you are fluent you actually aren't
even thinking about the language you're
speaking you you're thinking about like
what you what you are intending and what
you feel and what you want full enough
to think you're not thinking about the
numbers shuffling around and like how do
I make this work it all those good
things come automatically right so
that's why I keep going after equate
example I really interested in this
object here yeah plus 1 i'm so glad i'm
it's not forgiving some working there
for you can screw notice i'm doing after
this because well i heard some
conversations around the room that was
centered on confusion with this number
some people have might have fun some
people have +1 now this is really
important to me that you don't just hear
from me hey everyone the stock is rated
answers right because he's awesome and
that's really hold her to it okay even
if those things are true I don't want
you to look at this and learn this is
what I should do because I want you to
learn that the Y underneath the because
so that's why I wear it grant is so this
is a set of scale okay now the reason
why I've got this here is because you
have to picture one of these every
single time you see one of these we
measure this before right this equal
sign in the middle was it me means these
things but all that and the right there
same same value same size so when you
manipulate you can do the same thing to
both sign otherwise it's not
this in law it's not going to be equal
okay so it's not a matter so much on
this one creeps over the other side and
then some reason changes in clothes and
turns into a plus one like I remember I
learned Ryan's about how to take one
thing over to the other side and how it
changes there is nothing that moves
sides if that is really one of these in
what you're really doing is not moving
things back and forth but doing the same
thing to both sides do you understand
because otherwise it doesn't say balance
agree so what is the same thing that
Mustafa started both sides he has added
one to go science ok and that's why
firstly there is a pop on over here
where they would look hot on before but
you've kind of got a bit of a shortcut I
think most of us in so doing it ahead if
you add one to decide well what can
happen to this guy it's going to get
cancelled out because most 1+1 3 illegal
does that make sense it's not about ah
something's moving and it changes when
it moves nothing is moving you're just
keeping balance that's all you're doing
ok is it a deal with this plus 3x you
see where it's taco Terry's done he's
done it to both sides and that's why
everybody stays balanced which is why
one-third looks pretty good to me so I
got some thumbs up yes captain boys
bowling the surface area let's do this
quickly because we're doing this for a
while 625 cubic centimeters I turn 50
square centimeters agreement yes yes
nothing so that was going to cube when
you come over to the code yes Italy
lecture legwork though she wants the
extra leg work you have to do fantastic
because this is not the perpendicular
height it's the slant height that's it
ok when you're doing this time what was
the laws we are doing up here
so after Sarah only depends on Ruiz and
slight that's enough now you don't have
to do any extra Pythagoras or anything
like that one thousand million a precise
yeah yes no oh ok so where have we gone
wrong this one here so by the way by the
way this is actually very important you
should do this all the time it's a
muscle that needs to be flanked this
line he are actually everyone really
when you hit equals you should do a
sense check on right pi you don't have
to do exactly what it is what's hi
roughly that's really nice of a 32 bit
more than three obviously five times 13
that's low enough we should have a new
timetable on that right by 30 i'm pretty
sure that 65 65 times about three is
about 200 okay so therefore I know okay
something's gonna maybe I'll just punch
my numbers drawn into my calculator let
me just check it again can someone could
be a more accurate it's on anyone yeah i
supply the one yeah can I get two notes
from that yes because the more nods
start some people who are not hydrogen
sure it seems like a suitable path to be
read right there like 200 ish and that's
78.5 so yeah I'm okay with that that's
that bull ham pie a third PI R squared H
314 point to what do you think yeah 314
point 21 centimeters to confuse them in
and that's been rounded off to a decimal
place and I'll make sure with a
devaluating particularly there's no big
deal yeah that's not one to existing on
at the moment we'll worry about
approximation later